so let's look a little more closely at
aperture settings which in fact is a
discussion really about what we call
depth of field depth of field is about
what is in focus and what is not in
focus in your picture your aperture
setting on your lens sets the size of
your aperture or maybe it's easier to
think of it as a hole the size of that
hole determines how much of your image
is in focus when you set your lens to
the largest aperture that your lens
offers we say that your lens is wide
open and in that wide open setting is
what you see in your viewfinder if you
want to see what is in focus through
your viewfinder that is if you set your
aperture let's say at f 32 you'll have
to press the preview button to see what
will be in focus by pressing the preview
the aperture will close down to your
chosen f-stop and you'll see a darkened
image in your viewfinder it's another
reason why I use the software remember
in the software is live view we see the
image with the chosen aperture on the
screen much easier than seeing a
darkened image and trying to figure out
what's in focus there's no need to press
a preview button when you use software
so in our situation 28 is the largest
aperture in this particular 105 lens we
call it f-stop 2.8 or f28 notice that
the number is actually written as f over
2.8 when we set the diaphragm to those
numbers written on the lens the numbers
in fact represent fractions and for that
reason if / 28 is larger in terms of
size of the aperture then let's say F /
4 + f4 is larger than 56 and so on this
can be a little confusing but if you
think in terms of fractions it will make
more sense so these are the settings
we'll look at in this X
sighs you'll see more potential settings
on your lens but for our purposes here
these should be enough to make the point
about focus changes will stay with these
five okay now here's the image I made at
our music box at f/4 take a hard look at
what is in focus and what is not not
very much in the foreground and
background and so we say this image has
a narrow depth of field not a whole lot
is in focus now at 5.6 here is the image
again let's compare the two we're seeing
very slight changes in focus that's what
we're looking for take a hard look
what's in focus and now we'll go to f/8
and comparing f8 256 little by little
more of the image is coming into focus
you should stop the video and give the
two a careful look notice the turning
mechanism a tad more in focus with f8
and a tad more as well in the screws and
everything else in that object plane
will go the next f-stop f11 and we'll
compare to the previous image f8 and
again you should stop the video to make
the comparison and just to move things
along a bit we'll just go right to f 32
look at how small the aperture is and
look at how so much more of the image is
in focus compared to the previous now to
drive home the point even further let's
compare f32 with f4 so you really see a
significant change that's what these
observations are about we're seeing how
focus or depth of field changes more and
more gets into focus as we close down or
stop down the aperture to the smaller
fraction settings on your lens but
remember as we close the aperture to
smaller settings like f 32 we also
decrease the amount of light we let into
the camera we're not getting the right
exposure until we compensate by
increasing the amount
of time the shutter is open for example
when I change from one second to two
seconds I'm keeping the shutter open
twice as long allowing more light into
the camera the longer the shutter is
open the longer we permit the light to
enter the camera and to be read by the
sensor compensating for small aperture
settings